you take on f5 so that is not working  there's no time to really pick up this  pawn  tani let's back up let's see what  happens if we don't rush we're taking on  e5  and does black have something better  here so  green c7 queen c7 yeah i was thinking  that  yeah yeah so i was thinking to take on  f5  and now wait a second i'm gonna just  take you  yeah i'm afraid you can yes takes takes  takes and my king would suddenly be  vulnerable  i think in just a second i'll be in  trouble oh my god look at what's  happened on the board guys  take a look at that yes i don't know if  it's good  no we we like to award medals if you  guess a move correctly so we'd like to  award you our first medal of the day  mikhailon  no tanya guessed bishop d6 just now so  you know  listen i have no problem about awarding  medals to everybody queen c7